- Mole sauce is a very
special Mexican dish.
It's really the go-to plate
for any major celebration.
Our mole sauce started
from just a family recipe;
but now, we are making about
2,000 pounds of mole a day.
We never thought in our wildest dreams
that that was going to happen.
(emotional violin music)
(playful piano music)
There are nearly one million
Mexicans living in the tri-state area.
Half of them are from
Puebla, where we are from,
and they still want the
flavor from back home.
(Damiana speaking Spanish)
That's what we eat, she said.
My family has been producing
mole at Mole Poblano
La Asuncion for several years now.
The business is run by three
generations, all of them women:
my grandmother, my mother and me.
(uplifting violin music)
Mole just means a sauce
with a lot of ingredients:
chilies and spices
and sugar and chocolate.
We also use almonds,
raisins and sesame seeds.
We toast all of those ingredients up
and also have to grind them as well.
That's when we put the pot up,
and then we start heating the oil
with some garlic and with some onions.
And when the onions and garlic are done,
that's when start pouring in our chilies,
and that's when we start
putting the ingredients.
You have to have very strong
arms to keep stirring that mole
until everything is completely
integrated into the sauce,
until everything looks dark.
Our recipe, it takes about two days.
It has to go through
Grandma to get approved.
(speaking Spanish)
My grandmother moved to New
York from Piaxtla, Puebla
in the 1970s because she had children
and mouths to feed back home.
(speaking Spanish)
And then word of mouth started increasing.
Now, the mole sauce is
being distributed in bodegas
and Mexican stores and
restaurants here in New York
and in the tri-state area, and
also all around the country.
The longing for a little
something of where you come from
I think played in our success
here in New York City.
It's authentic as it can possibly be.
The most important part of our day
is at 2 o'clock in the afternoon
when we have lunch together as a family.
I guess it's a very big expression
of how much we love our
job, we love our mole,
and we love each other in the family.
I guess that transfers also in
the mole sauce that we make.
(electronic chiming)